I don't have time very sure but
genetically engineered to stop aging at
25 but why does this movie ever explain
why how this came to be no no it does
not just deal with it time is now the
currency will be chooses an expositional
monologue that reveals a central conceit
of the movie instead of showing it to us
in a much more interesting way without
context I just want to wake up with more
time on my hand and hours in the day but
if you were down to around 24 hours why
would you even sleep you've got a date
Olivia get out there and hustle some
more hours
how much hardware is required to make
this on the skin displayable even work
this is like three surgeries worth of
bullshit right you can't do this with
genetic modification happy fiftieth yep
that's his mom even though the actor
Timberlake is a few years older than
Olivia a while this movie's
understanding of time allows for them to
appear to be the same age thanks not
philip k dick 25 for the 25th time
actually if she's 50 years old she'd be
25 for the 26th time but Justin wasn't
told there would be math involved in
this movie heavily reliant on Matt I was
sure I'd have a grandchild by now so
will is 28 years old perfect baby-making
age but since everyone's bodies remain
physically 25 does that mean everyone
can procreate into their hundreds I can
make extra on the side you know fighting
nobody wins in that case the book you
should be pretty upset I just wouldn't
know what to do if I lost it reverse for
shot irony
so shaking hands with someone in this
universe results in time changing hands
it's not like they have timers or
controllers in this scene they just
clasp hands and then watch the clocks on
their wrists I mean how many times have
folks in this world given up their time
on accident just because they touched
someone else the wrong wait I'm give you
30 minutes you can have a decent lunch
how does the arm timer know when to stop
is it controlled by the brain but
stopped at 30 minutes donated flat how
did it do that I'd be goddamned it this
movie explains anything the name of this
beer is a nice time-related pun but it
costs an hour earlier Will's mom gave
him 30 minutes for a decent meal but a
fucking six-pack will set an average
person back 4% of their lifespan another
one broad daylight and his corpse is
just hanging out in the middle of the
workforce does this movie need Sally
Field to step in and organize a union in
the future money will be replaced by
time genetic modification is rampant and
yet factories will still somehow need to
employ humans to operate a lever I think
the scariest part of this future is that
we'll be wearing a button suits
anything stupid go I'm only going to
obviously stand here and watch some guys
kill another guy from 20 feet away
that's not stupid right and this is a
very nice watch this statement brings up
an interesting point why don't more
people have watches in this movie sure
they have time printed on their arm but
that's only the time they have left what
if they have a doctor's appointment or
want to catch a movie um is anyone gonna
notice the obvious Timberlake buy a
stander in the background no okay
at the moment not only does Henry
ludicrously ask for a moment to puke
before he dies these assholes give it to
him ready to go wait will was standing
in the stall this whole time he couldn't
have come in after Henry since The Goon
followed him so he had to know Henry was
gonna do some pre death vomiting Jesus
this movie has already broadcast that
it's brain wasn't a line item in the
budget this dumpster that was easily
movable by will is somehow able to hold
off many strong men from opening the
door I know who took him I know who he
is also how the does discount Ryan
Filipino who will is he didn't have one
look at his face when he got knocked out
in the bathroom he saved till morning
I'll get you out of here yeah I'm sure
those large men with guns are just gonna
forget all about this incident even
though at least one of them is literally
outside the front door and I'm standing
in plain sight 105 but the day comes
when you've had enough your mind can be
spent even if your body's not sure but
Henry's whole suicide by drunken fight
with gangsters plan ensures those
fuckers get his time instead of donating
it the people who could really use it
why do you think there are time zones
because the earth is gigantic the truth
is there's more than enough no one has
to die before their time but what is
everyone's time movie yada yada spaz
sickness murderer accidents and any
other cause of death besides running out
of King time this plot would be perfect
for a Twilight Zone episode but instead
is stretched out to a whole movie I'm
honestly surprised those assholes with
guns who were directly outside this
building last night decided not to
inspect it first off this is some pretty
goddamn non-consensual time swapping
here don't you have to have a willing
participant before you go sticking your
minutes inside someone also earlier it
took wills mom a decent chunk of time to
transfer thirty minutes to him but Henry
transfers more than a fucking century in
less than 18 seconds even goddamn
newborns have the green timers did they
somehow make this green clock bullshit
part of the common genetic code the fuck
look at this where did you get that
even though he saw the dude last night
that had all the time Burrell must think
there's a possibility we'll ran into
another person that might have gifted
him some sweet future currency
okay after being treated for having too
much obvious time which will get him
killed in the zone will gives Burrell a
bunch of obvious time in the hopes it
won't get him killed in this zone
received two hours to walk goddamnit
movie mamas Alice just looked all happy
about making her loan payment that was
two fucking days but she only left
herself an hour and a half and after
paying what she thought was the one hour
bus fare she'd have thirty fifteen
minutes if it's a two-hour can walk the
bus ride must take at least thirty
minutes especially with stops mother the
stupid movie takes an awesome premise
and pisses all over it let's just be
honest we've all had a dream where
Olivia Wilde was our mother right oh you
imagined her as your oh god that's nasty
what's wrong with you
oh they're both running well then I
guess she's gonna die within sight of
him a mom dies because she stupidly
spent all our time on a loan payment and
didn't have enough to make it to meet
her son who is suddenly flush with
currency cliche I'm sorry but
Timberlake's crying over his mom's death
here is pretty hilarious and you thought
the crying Jordan mean was over-the-top
how long you been keeping time Jaeger
five years let me know what you're
thinking you've been doing it for 50 Wow
sick burn detective but if this guy has
been on the force for five years
shouldn't he already be aware how long
you've been doing this what would you
like us to do sir what we always do all
the time you know kind of like Prince
and the revolution did in purple ring
I'll give you ten minutes for an hour
this is the most confusing proposition
of all time we don't normally make
pickups in this zone
so how the fuck did will get the contact
information for this transport service
and why didn't anyone in Dayton notice
this nice ass car where and when did
we'll get this fancy ass looking suit
did he bury his mother already why is
this movie so dumb and he's blowing past
all the other time zones he's never
experienced missing out on the famous
sights and pleasures each might have to
offer above the only zone he's ever
known the outermost super pores oh sure
he's obviously got some kind of goal but
all I'm saying is he's acting like only
the very richest most exclusive time
zone has anything interesting to offer
which can't possibly be true I'm gonna
take them for everything they've got at
escalated quickly
he went from my mom just died to the
entire system up in like a day also
driver continues to casually drive after
hearing an obvious threat to his way of
life supposedly utopian new Greenwich
looks a lot more like suburban Galveston
totally by happenstance JT shows up here
just as the redheaded wig girls arriving
and longing for someone to stare at also
JT
Olivia Wilde and Amanda ciphered this is
like a Shawn at uh C or Dominique Swain
appearance away from being a full-bore
alpha dog reunion
it's fast it's gonna have to be but they
must have just seen Henry dial-up
without will even touching it so why do
they immediately think he's the one that
took his time that'll be eight and a
half weeks
dang one week shy of a mickey rourke
movie also let's break this down a
standard room is two months or sixty
days
breakfast is eight and a half weeks or
basically sixty days a room here and
breakfast here cost the exact same think
about that the society is either
devaluing hotel rooms or way over
valuing eggs I probably don't have to
tell you this about JT but as long as
he's got that suit in time he's gonna
leave it all on the floor tonight so
he's got a hundred years told the limo
driver he's here to fuck the entire
system and he goes gambling how much
high-stakes poker did he play back in
the slums to be this fucking confident
also good to know that in the dystopian
future people will not only still be
playing Texas Hold'em but it'll still be
a fucking sausage fest wait is this shot
telling me he now has 250 years he's 150
years at poker already and no one
thought to discuss who he was or where
he came from until now so if she's not
outside the hotel right when JT arrives
to get infatuated with him none of the
rest of the movie is even possible just
FYI always been survival of the fittest
raise you another two centuries
literally down to his last 27 seconds
what a stupid fucking bet not to mention
if that small talk about survival of the
fittest had gone on even 30 seconds
longer this bet might not even have gone
through but mostly what a stupid can bet
[Music]
and Silvia quietly climaxes under the
table also yeah he wins what the ever I
don't think this movie pokers any better
than it futures that was some risk that
was some understatement
drive it man wills plan to take down the
cultural elite to avenge his mom's death
by gambling and buying expensive cars is
going perfectly and my daughter Sylvia I
believe you two have already met
Philippe says this slyly like he didn't
introduce them to each other two movie
minutes ago
and we have yet another example of the
screenwriters cramming unnecessary James
Bond tea and cliches into the script
okay will is smart enough to know that
Philippe is not to be trusted
so therefore dancing with Philippe's
daughter is dangerous but apparently the
allure of the redhead is too much for
will these two are able to run away from
the party with on a single escort
bodyguard or even a curious voyeur we
don't go in how did you evolve to be
afraid of the ocean or is it somehow
poison but instead of saying it's poison
do you say you're insane
they're time-codes be glowing while
we'll soundless be growing and yes those
time codes would be emitting light and
all but they've never been shown to be
this bright it's like we needed a way to
show the leads faces while they're
skinny-dipping in the grotto section of
the ocean they both got dried off and
back into their clothes and basically
record time for this scene to be
possible how about that candidate Jesus
who's the actual antagonist in this
movie Papa Weiss the detective new
Greenwich the gangsters in Dayton time
itself andrew niccol these cops bust in
and grab will for questioning and then
take him upstairs in the house the party
is going on in while Willy gets
questioned in an 18th century French
parlor I'm left to ask about the guards
guns what are they for can you shoot
someone who still has tons of time on
their wrists and if you do what happens
to that time and also who thought C
green and gold was a good combination
for this room I can only assume wills
plan to up in society is going a
schedule and that he intended to get all
his time taken and himself in prison
this is a gathering of some of the
richest people in the world security is
tight and there's a gaggle of policeman
to arrest will but only one asshole is
out here guarding the parking lot pretty
amazing that you can see LA's I mean new
Greenwich is skyscrapers from the same
angle here is in Dayton I gotta ask
coming from the slums has he even driven
before
my point is that he shouldn't have an up
driving experience to be this good but
yet he does no cop trailing a fleeing
suspect with a hostage would ever RAM
the car the hostage is in that's in
laughable movie I know you need action
in tension but try to leave at least a
10% connection to reason not only was
Leon the only police officer to give
chase from the house he immediately
gives up after getting into a fender
bender he
covered anybody cz you're definitely
dead but why unless they work back to
the ghetto somehow there's still a new
Greenwich which should be the safest
place in the world we'll had a little
more than an hour left after they
escaped from the house party and it was
pitch dark but now it's broad daylight
and he's very not dead they both
survived this
I can't tell is it irony or incompetence
that has these same officers back at the
same LA River for yet another crime
scene
I mean it's cyclical right he's back in
his own neighborhood looking how even if
it doesn't cost any time to get from the
riches owned to the poor zone there were
barriers and checkpoints going both ways
on the trip to new Greenwich
look I know they're in the ghetto and
everything but wills walking down the
middle of the goddamn street with a gun
pointed at Silvia Wow thank God he gave
her a gun am i right his shot was
words.you time down but I took my
sweet-ass time getting here just in case
we don't cute together well maybe that
should still be like the 15th furthest
thing from your mind right now after
escape escape escape and 12 more escape
thoughts you've forgotten I shot a cop
our time keepers really cops I thought
they just kept track of time for the
various districts but do they
investigate other non time related
criminal acts like arson
you can go back go back to life oh I
don't know security immortality caviar
was that objectionable I don't have a
choice
I'm starting to think that I don't
either movie veers jarringly into a
meditation of life in the meaning of
existence and the disparity between
classes in a society and I could not
give viewers romance by proximity
there's almost no reason for them to be
kissing except the last few hours spent
together and a bit of Stockholm Syndrome
this map informs us that Philippe is on
the phone with the American West Coast
the entirety of Europe most of Central
Africa and Moscow which means I guess
the rest of the world is ghettoized what
about white
after being recently shot in the street
to the ghetto detective redeye is right
back to evening without any difficulty
this is cog a trigger you don't pull it
until you actually want to shoot
something first off these two have hours
left but somehow they have time for
witty banter and target practice second
she just shot the moving detective that
was about to kill will so I don't think
she needs much direction on firearms I
can hope you get overtime
and finally wills take them for all
they're worth plan pays off after
countless instances where he could have
and should have died prior to this this
was the plan to steal an armored truck
and Ram it into a bank that for some
reason has a wide-open vault
okay fine but why did will need Silvia
for this caper he couldn't come up with
this on his own why has nobody tried
this before if it's a cz come on help
yourselves
take it causing a literal riot for your
getaway I mean there is no question
one-fourth of these people are dead by
the time this bank vault is empty right
huh
at this point I'm willing to believe
Leon is actually a series of clones
considering he's able to get from the
ghetto to new Greenwich and back in
seconds Sylvia Weis withdrew some of her
inheritance when she and will Salas
robbed her father's time bank for the
sixth time in a week looking 6th time
now where the bank's not hip to the hole
drive an armored truck through the front
door scheme after the first one also
shouldn't the timekeepers just be
keeping an eye out for the fucking
armored truck that has dents and glass
shards all over it why do I play strip
poker with you why did you hide wager
it's because it's been 40 minutes since
this movie showed any skin wheels
character was introduced as a fighter
but his biggest attribute thus far has
been long-distance running which is
obviously much more entertaining than
seeing him actually fight someone to
look familiar how about now goddamn
everyone in this movie is motivated by
currency over everything else and I'm
gonna clean the cross off of every one
of you in this hellhole until someone
says something I wanna hear gotta be
honest no idea who this guy is I know
I've seen him a couple times in this
movie and he's clearly bad but other
than that I'm lost with a reward like
ten years these two are screwed right I
mean ten years in the ghetto is like a
hundred years elsewhere right he catches
there's no way they won't kill us movie
that started off as 1984 then morphed
into Casino Royale then became Robin
Hood now wants to be Bonnie and Clyde
well I guess they're in love now then
ain't fortunately for you I don't like
to kill a man in cold blood
I like to give him the plot information
let him escape easily then futile II
chase him for a few minutes before
giving up that's my kind of thing after
I take you I'll take her all bad guys
are rapists
these armwrestling fights make no
goddamn sense first we've never seen an
actual fight to this point in the movie
so there's no point of reference second
how the fuck does it work is it a battle
of wills of strength of who can pad the
movies runtime the longest listen if all
these were just standing around staring
at this fight while we'll pulls out a
gun they deserve to die
stop Sylvia Weis the most wanted woman
in every time zone is able to not only
travel from Dayton back to new Greenwich
but can walk the through the front door
of this building you see this is what
happens when you don't properly check
references you mistakenly hire the guy
who kidnapped your daughter at gunpoint
and is actively trying to bring down
your international banking scheme wait
last we saw these two they were all the
way over in the slums and then they get
an idea and what waltz all the way back
to new Greenwich without any trouble at
any other time zone stops let's go for a
ride and the three of them got away with
no one following phew and wire me my per
diem wait never mind I have him yes but
does Leon really think even in the best
of circumstances that this arrest will
take less than 45 minutes and couldn't
he pursue them while he's getting his
per diem wait never mind I haven't yeah
that's right kids just happened to drive
past the people I'm looking for in this
huge city because movie if I gave any
more because I'd literally be upset
they've now set enough to have Dayton
directly adjacent to new Greenwich even
though there should be several other
time zones between them is that thing
being bulletproof somehow or did no one
shoot at the tires this movie suggests a
crowd of desperate poor people would all
share in the spoils evenly which anyone
who has ever studied American history
can tell you is a first and a half yeah
I know it's personal all now but is it
Leon's still more concerned about the
system crashing than these two criminals
the million year capsule is right in the
middle of town for God's sake one of us
can make it take my arguing over who
should go will almost definitely end up
killing both these fools or at least it
should what are the odds that this guy
once again finds himself literally
racing toward a female he hopes to save
with his time and cutting it too close I
mean yeah parallel narratives or
whatever but the odds still make this
scene
kind of stupid right Sylvie has been
running all this away in heels despite
being on TV levels of wanted neither of
these fools have changed their
appearance yet
[Music]
singing kill my grandma okay
dance with me so your idea is to get a
van and cruise the streets looking for
kids to pick up yes its Peter Campbell
from Sterling Cooper for Clarence
Hastings how come here is like a gas and
sip on Saturday not completely long
drinking beers no women anywhere like
twice